the Joe Rogan experience pretty sure
they showed steep Bay just pulling off
of DC was that the case that was a yeah
I got my whole phone got blown up cuz
apparently I'm right in the back when
that happens I don't know I've exceeded
but blew up right there that was that
fight was chaos down the fight was Kay I
was fun I had an amazing time that card
I should say that card fight card was
chaos yeah there was a wild one man in
Anaheim
it was hard watching TC get hit with
those [ __ ] body shot oh yeah dude
soon as he started digging in it was
like oh wow something's happening dude
ste pays nasty
he wanted that belper shots he took
incredible you know we were talking
about yo the shots T paid took and I
walk through them like well I was crazy
because DC managed to put him away with
one punch the first time and he didn't
see coming
ya see incoming everything you got hit
with was hard as hell but he saw it all
coming yep I mean he's let him get in
that little right in his chest there cuz
that's what he got that short one on him
that last time that's exactly what
happens if you're not prepared if you
don't think you're gonna get punched and
you relax for a minute and then you get
punched by something you don't see
coming you can get [ __ ] up and when
you're in a fight with a greco-roman
wrestler of the caliber of DC knows how
to manipulate you and he just been
manipulated him perfectly into that
right hand and it was a beautiful work
of art but he was never able to hit him
like that in the second fight like as
cleanly and have that kind of an effect
the shots he hit him with were pretty
good shots but steep they ate him and
then you realize oh Steve I can't take a
[ __ ] shot he just got cooked he just
got caught he could take a [ __ ] shot
and he was there in the fourth round
which is really impressive like in the
fourth round he was looking good he
recognizes him soon as he touched that
net never shot that it was yep Wow
something happened there and it hit him
he dug in like four or five straight
times man cannot let a guy like that
punch you in the liver that many times
I'm sure DC obviously didn't want him to
do that but that's how good Steve is
selected do you see them yeah I respect
GC I love that guy that was grace he's
one of my favorite people to do
commentary with man for sure he's he's
the best he's so fun he's hilarious like
when thought
ROS Nami unist knocked out that is what
I love like he's a friend
moment he's so free that in the middle
of like this crate we're calling a world
title fight
he's just DC he could be himself and
it's uh he's got a great personality man
and he's a hell of a fighter and he was
dominating in the first round she think
he's gonna go he gonna go fight again I
think he's gonna want to fight steep
again if I guess if I really guess I
mean if he wants to do it again he's
gonna want to fight Steve bacon because
he's gonna want to what I think the way
he described it is right that wrong that
he did he just didn't fight well he
didn't listen to his corner I think
that's what he thinks it's like he
fought really well in the first round
and then Bob Cooke was yelling at him in
the second round keep your damn hands up
you know and he he was like walking him
down like almost like disdainfully like
walk him down and I don't know if that
was a part of strategy to
psychologically put up a lot of pressure
on steep a you know to try to establish
that steep base done that he's the champ
now but it was almost like disdainful
but steep they survived so and he just
was there and he was in there in really
good shape and rounds three and rounds
four that was what was really impressive
about it that was I was amazed
especially after getting [ __ ] up quite
a bit in that first round I mean there
was a couple times where I thought he
was gonna be fit like I do was gonna get
him yeah DC was all over him in that
first round and when he when he picked
him up and dumped dumped me like Jesus
Christ DC's good yeah Jesus Christ he's
good
he just didn't maintain it that's
exactly what it was and then steep I
made the adjustment and you know who the
[ __ ] knows he might decide you know what
my body doesn't want to do this anymore
I'm done I know he made a ton of money
and I know he's really good as a
commentator and he'll would he'll do
that forever for sure or he might don't
want to do it one more time but then
there's always John Jones were lurking
man John Jay felt like everybody knows
like that's the biggest rivalry in MMA
isn't it isn't it yeah I mean the only
thing you give if you're gonna talk
about accolades of core means he has
everything all those championships but
there's that little asterisk
yeah on the on the light heavyweight
belt that he never really got it from
Ryan but that's the weird part about it
right it's like when you're a champion
but the champion who's the real champion
didn't lose it and then they have an
interim Jim what are we doing here what
does happen is he gonna never come back
and and and shown that he's still him
like and hopefully God willing for him
keeping all his stuff together and yeah
it would have been different if he just
kind of faded into the distance and then
it changes that narrative but he came
back and and he his original thing was
like you ain't that guy I'm that guy
still yeah it was crazy
I mean Jed that's how crazy good John is
really that's how crazy good John is